bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat hier l'ambassadeur du mexique en
france a quitté l'hémicycle du sénat au
moment où michèle alliot marie ministre
des affaires étrangères évoquait le cas
de florence cassez cette française
condamnée à 60 ans de prison au mexique
l'ambassadeur du mexique assisté avec
d'autres ambassadeurs sud-américains à
une séance du sénat qui visait à
instaurer une journée de l'amérique
latine et des caraïbes en france le 31
mai michèle alliot marie a pris la
parole estimant qu'il y avait une
actualité et qu'aujourd'hui cette
actualité c'était le cas de florence k
16 même si la ministre a rappelé le
respect de la france pour la justice
mexicaine ceci a suscité un certain émoi
et c'est donc cette séance que je vous
propose de revoir ce matin très bonne
matinée à tous l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
relative à l'institution d'une journée
de l'amérique latine et des caraïbes en
france présentée en application de
l'article 34 de la constitution par
messieurs jean marc pastor roland du
luart philippe adnot gérard cornu et
bernard piras et plusieurs de leurs
collègues dans le débat la parole est un
monsieur jean marc pastor auteur de la
proposition de résolution
matt smaby le premier prix
qui
je
monsieur le président madame la ministre
d'état mes chers collègues
c'est avec une certaine émotion que je
prends la parole dans cette enceinte
pour soutenir devant vous une initiative
qui s'inscrit dans une démarche que l'on
voudra bien qualifié d'historique ce
n'est pas tous les jours en effet que
par delà les contingences de l'actualité
nous sommes réunis pour examiner un
texte qui je l'espère marquera les
relations entre la france et tout un
continent
respectueux de la tradition française
celle qui fait notre richesse celle qui
rapproche les peuples celle qui mobilise
avec enthousiasme la joie de vivre
ensemble celle de la main tendue vers
l'autre celle des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen cette force
nous l'avons nous elle vivre de tous nos
ports et sort de nos entrailles notre
assemblée a tenu l'an dernier à
s'associer aux célébrations qui ont
marqué pour un grand nombre de pays les
premières manifestations de leur
indépendance
ses premiers cris de libération des
peuples comme l'a écrit en historien en
termes excellent
ces derniers jours nous avons pu voir en
direct la joie d'hommes et de femmes il
sans connaître leur sort de demain
venait de gagner leur liberté d'être
humain mais nous nous nous le savons
qu'en sera-t-il demain sans
accompagnement sans soutien le pire peut
aussi être à traîne
la liberté est le fruit d'une guerre à
un moment donné est un combat permanent
pour la maintenir et la protéger
ce soutien de tous s'impose à nous
soyons vigilants elle est si fragile
brandissant l'étendard sanglant comme
notre hymne national évoque mais pour
empêcher que le sang ne coule en
amérique latine
les premiers mouvements dans la
diversité de leurs portes et ont été
pour beaucoup inspirés par les
différents courants de ce que l'on a
appelé les lumières même si la france ne
fut pas l'unique inspiratrice des élites
de l'époque on peut rappeler sans
solliciter l'histoire qu'elles influent
largement à la source
dès la deuxième moitié du xviiie siècle
imprimerie du nouveau-monde diffuser
largement les oeuvres des philosophes
français toute bibliothèque digne de ce
nom se devait de compter l'encyclopédie
sur ses rayons et les échanges
épistolaires entre les gens d'esprit
emprunter pour beaucoup de thèmes à ceux
du continent européen
l'étude de l'histoire des différents
pays montre la densité et la
multiplicité des références à la
révolution française les grandes figures
ce que l'on appellera plus tard les
pères fondateurs parlait souvent le
français où était pétri de culture
française
n'est ce pas un certain antonio narines
ion qui traduira dans son cabinet de
bogota la déclaration de l'homme et du
citoyen et qui l'a répandra dans tout le
pays a grand grand dam des autorités
coloniales qu'il se souvient du jeune
francisco de miranda citoyenne de ce qui
n'était pas encore le venezuela qui
grand admirateur de la révolution
française s'engagera dans l'armée de du
mouriès pour en sortir avec le grade de
général et bolivar la grande figure par
excellence de l'émancipation des peuples
latino avait pour précepteur un disciple
affiché de rousseau ses années de
jeunesse et de formation furent eux
durablement marquée par la lecture de
l'emile j'aurais gardé de m'engager dans
une énumération qui serait fastidieuse
et au demeurant
certainement inutile les faits sont
suffisamment connue pour qu'il ne soit
pas nécessaire d'y revenir
dans le détail pour évoquer ces moments
historiques qui ont compté dans la
formation de l'identité nationale des
états du continent latino-américain la
république française se devait de
prendre une initiative symbolique est
forte
c'est le sens c'est le sens de la
proposition de résolution madame la
ministre que j'ai déposée avec mes
collègues membres des différents groupes
d'amitié du sénat que je veux saluer et
qui a reçu l'accueil enthousiaste de pas
moins de 115 collègues appartenant à
tous les groupes politiques de notre
assemblée
au-delà de ces faits historiques
tous ces pays avec des degrés différents
de rattachement à l'histoire française
vinci franchissent tous les jours un peu
plus les marques de la liberté et de la
démocratie
ils ne sont plus des pays en voie de
développement comme les dénommés il y à
peu encore soumis à des régimes parfois
autoritaire mais des acteurs de vrais
acteurs du monde à part entière libre
souverain maîtres de leur destinée
leur niveau de formation leur souci de
protéger la démocratie parfois chèrement
acquise et les valeurs qui s'y
rattachent leur richesse intellectuelle
économiques culturels artistiques mais
aussi mais aussi leurs besoins fonds
qu'ils peuvent être des partenaires
irremplaçable de notre pays et qu'il
nous appartient de répondre à leurs
attentes
nous avons tant temps à nous enrichir
mutuellement
2010 fut une année exceptionnelle
une sorte d'expérience de vie commune
partagée avec les ambassadrices et les
ambassadeurs tout le corps diplomatique
des pays d'amérique latine et caraïbes
réunis dans le grand lac mais aussi avec
les institutions nombreuses qui en
france oeuvrent pour l'amitié avec ce
continent
mes collègues
présidents des groupes d'amitié le sénat
et son président le quai d'orsay bien
sûr et son savoir faire
oui cette expérience qui nous a conduit
à participer et à organiser ensemble
diverses manifestations pour honorer
avec tout l'éclat qu'il méritait le
bicentenaire de la libération de ces
pays
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être presque un
goût d'inachevé doit se prolonger de
façon différente nouvelles innovantes
audacieuse car le lien qui s'est tissée
au fil du temps ne fut pas un lien
programme est absolument pas mais une
réaction spontanée naturelle celle du
peuple celle du coeur pour prolonger ces
célébrations leur donner un sens et en
conserver une trace pérenne et célébrer
mutuellement nos valeurs et vous est
proposé d'adopter une proposition de
résolution demandant au gouvernement
l'établissement chaque année à date fixe
d'une journée de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes
en france le 31 mai ainsi pour nous à
date fixe et chaque année organisé des
manifestations sur tout le territoire de
la république et rassembler nos
compatriotes et tous les amis de
l'amérique latine et des caraïbes qui
sont des milliers et des milliers sur
notre sol dans des moments de
convivialité et je veux l'espérer dans
les grès partager mêlant à la fois la
culture et la réflexion
les anniversaires ne doivent pas
uniquement être l'occasion d'évoquer le
passé
ils sont aussi surtout le moyen de se
projeter dans l'avenir afin de mieux le
préparer à la lumière des acquis de
l'histoire sur ce chemin du partage des
difficultés parfois nous attendent
à nous de savoir les analyses et les
surmonter pour aller de l'avant
notre proximité historique l'autre
latinité notre patrimoine culturel
commun en saurons davantage fortifiée il
y avait que les liens d'amitié qui nous
attachent chercher à mieux se connaître
est la démarche de tout acteur politique
et économique cherchaient à se
rencontrer pour apprécier les modes de
vie et les règles établies par chacun
pour enfin pour enfin avoir de vraies
relations partager innover innover sur
un continent laisse l'avantagé de la
souplesse car d'un pays à l'autre
les choses peuvent différer à un moment
donné mais dans la durée
cela permet d'assurer la constance des
liens forts et bénéfique pour tous
en partant de la protection de la
démocratie et en évitant des crises oui
madame la ministre
oui là la france se retrouve son visage
du siècle des lumières
c'est cette france là que nous aimons
celle que les latinos m
celle qui donne et qui partagent avant
de chercher à recevoir tout au long du
chemin que la vie se trouve en
permanence se cacher derrière en virage
un danger un obstacle qu'il faut savoir
dominer qu'il faut savoir vaincre et la
lhomme seul le pays seuls à toujours
plus de mal à dominer chacune de ces
difficultés le groupe lui est une union
union de force une union de choix union
d'amour qui permet à chacun de franchir
plus allègrement ses difficultés
ceci c'est à la france de par son
histoire de par le message dont elle est
porteuse de le proposer et d'un être si
possible un acteur puissant dames la
ministre associez vous à nous dans un
acte unique qui scellera l'amitié de la
france pour tout un continent
notre proposition est comme une étoile
de vie ou si on préfère la flamme qu'il
faut entretenir pour maintenir l'
enthousiasme et l'espoir de ceux qui la
contemple les défis se bâtit pierre
après pierre un parfois peut s'écrouler
mais les fondations sont inébranlables à
nous à nous de maintenir l' envie de
revenir sur le chantier jamais fini
toujours en mouvement ce chantier du
coeur et des hommes qui rassemble qui
permet de bâtir un monde meilleur
ce rendez vous annuel permettra de
s'assurer que la vie commune existe que
l'espoir est toujours vivace et que les
valeurs partagées sont plus importantes
que tout est maintenant en maintenant la
voie tracée par les lumières
voici plus de 200 ans la france est
égale à elle-même elle rassemble et u10
le 8 décembre dernier au sénat lors de
la célébration solennelle du
bicentenaire salle médicis
monsieur pierre lellouche alors ministre
des affaires européennes présent a bien
voulu au nom du gouvernement a apporté
son soutien à notre projet et je l'en
remercie à nouveau
c'est fort de cet appui et d
encouragement des représentants des
corps diplomatiques présentes dans notre
tribune aujourd'hui une autre tribune
d'honneur que je veux saluer également
et de celui de nos 115 collen
cosignataires d'une démarche partagée
tour politique confondue avec l'ensemble
des groupes d'amitié leur président que
je vous invite
mes chers collègues mesdames messieurs a
voté avec l' enthousiasme qu'elle
appelle la présente proposition de
résolution
le peuple de france vous en remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite du
débat la parole est à monsieur roland du
luart pour le groupe ump pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
d'état mes chers collègues
j'interviens aujourd'hui en ma qualité
de président du groupe d'amitié france
brésil que j'ai l'honneur d'animer
depuis trois ans après avoir présidé
successivement de 1991 à 2008
les groupes régionaux france amérique
latine et france amérique du sud dont le
brésil couvre la moitié du territoire
comme tous ceux qui sont très attachés
au renforcement des liens avec ce
continent qui s'intéresse à son avenir
qui veulent travailler et déplore la
perte d'influencé du français j'estime
qu'il est grand temps d'accorder plus
d'importance aux pays d'amérique latine
qui en quelques années ont connu pour la
plupart une formidable évolution et dire
et affirmer la présence de la france en
ce sens l'adoption de la proposition de
résolution aujourd'hui soumise à votre
examen me paraît particulièrement
opportune en effet que de chemin
parcouru dans nos relations bilatérales
depuis 1964 1 d où le général de gaulle
effectué sa tournée historique en
amérique latine il avait été le premier
à comprendre l'immense enjeux que
représente et pour l'europe pour la
france ce continent si proche de nous
par sa volonté d'indépendance nationale
et par ses références culturelles
le premier il avait su lui adresser le
message de liberté de fraternité de la
france
or les vicissitudes de l'histoire
politique et économique et d'autres
celle de l'amérique latine ont distendu
nos liens avec ce continent
un temps assimilé dans bien des esprits
à un tiers monde lointain et instable
certes des fragilités des difficultés
persistent qu'elles soient de nature
politique économico sociale il ne faut
pas les ignorer
mais en quelques années que de progrès
accomplis par les pays de cette région
je voudrais à cet égard évoqué quelques
points concernant le brésil à commencer
par nos relations
d'amitié anciennes et durable que j'ai
désormais à coeur d'approfondir la
france où le savait et éprouve pour le
brésil une amitié profonde
le brésil occupe une place toute
particulière dans notre vision du monde
il est pour les française et pour les
français une civilisation porteuse d'un
art de vivre d'une culture notamment
d'une culture politique d'un espoir pour
l'avenir
il est une source permanente de rêve et
d'inspiration je pense notamment à ce
grand rêve d'or et de mystère qui mena
sur les côtés dans les villes
brésiliennes et jusqu'aux tréfonds
d'amazonie tant de français en quête
d'une nouvelle vie et d'un nouvel
horizon
je me dis que peut-être à sa manière la
france a pu être un rêve pour le brésil
je pense à la france des lumières à la
france républicaine dont on retrouve le
bonnet phrygien sur les pièces de
monnaie ou encore à la france d'auguste
comptes dont la formule ordre et progrès
est devenu la devise même du brésil
c'est ce socle commun cette latinité
partagé qui explique la proximité qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui
il est vrai que de nos 100 ans d'autant
plus proche de brésil que le brésil est
un voisin limitrophes de la france
puisque nous partageons avec lui plus de
700 km de frontière commune avec le
territoire du département français de la
guyane
bientôt un grand pont enjambera l'aurait
enjambera l'oyapock
et ce pont ne sera pas seulement un
ouvrage d'art audacieux il manifestera
concrètement l'amitié franco brésilien
ensemble et nous appartient aujourd'hui
de bâtir d'autres ponts dans tous les
domaines c'est tout le sens du
partenariat stratégique lancé en 2006
par le président jacques chirac est
impulsée par l'adoption d'un plan
d'action ambitieux entre les présidents
lula et sarkozy en 2008
il ne s'agit pas en effet d'un banal
accord commercial
il s'agit pas d'un traité de plus dans
l'agenda des relations internationales
c'est un véritable acte qui concrétise
enfin au niveau qu'elle méritait
d'atteindre
une amitié cordiale et solide ce
partenariat a d'ailleurs dynamiser de
manière spectaculaire nos relations
bilatérales dans tous les domaines
militaires spatiales et désertique
migratoires ou en matière d aide au
développement pour autant no comment ne
pas être plus attentifs plus réactif et
finalement plus entreprenants si l'on
considère que le brésil est le cinquième
pays du monde en termes de population et
en superficie la huitième économie
mondiale devant la russie et l'inde
désormais reconnu comme un acteur
incontournable de la scène
internationale le brésil doit être pour
nous un partenaire majeur
ils partagent avec nous la même vision
d'une mondialisation mieux maîtriser
plus équitable plus juste et ceci dans
le cadre d'un monde multipolaire
la france et le brésil ont donc vocation
naturelle à agir ensemble en vue des
mêmes objectifs
le partenariat stratégique permettra
justement à nos deux pays de parler
d'une même voix dans les grands rendez
vous internationaux
c'est pourquoi comme le président
sarkozy est comme le gouvernement
français je suis favorable à l'entrée du
brésil comme membre permanent au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies nous
devons adapter des institutions
internationales
au 21ème siècle le brésil et à travers
lui l'amérique latine ne peut en être
exclus pour ma part je souhaite à cet
instant souligné l'excellence des liens
politiques qui unissent le brésil et la
france
car ils forment un arrière-plan très
propice au développement des échanges
économiques et commerciaux
notre coopération scientifique et
technique fondée sur le partenariat et
le cofinancement est également
considérée comme exemplaire
la france est ainsi le deuxième
partenaire scientifique du brésil après
les états unis
notre coopération culturelle est
également très encourageantes malgré le
déplacement du français vers l'espagnol
dans le cursus scolaire
trois lycées français totalise deux
mille élèves dont 500 français les
alliances françaises constituent le
réseau le plus ancien et le plus dense
du monde avec 39 implantations
accueillons plus de trente six mille
quatre cents élèves
pour autant la france doit être
attentives au maintien et au
renforcement de ses liens politiques
économiques et commerciaux avec le
brésil
grâce à ce partenariat sans précédent je
suis convaincu que le brésil sera
accepté l'ouverture de ses propres
marchés
en réponse aux efforts significatifs
opérés notamment par l'union européenne
en particulier dans le secteur agricole
et que le savoir faire de nos
entreprises grandes ou petites pourra
s'exprimer pleinement dans ce pays ami
la convergence d'analysé d'initiative
entre la france et brésil me confortent
dans la certitude que l'amitié franco
brésilienne aujourd'hui plus dense plus
risque promesse que jamais sert non
seulement les intérêts de nos deux pays
c'est évident mais encore ceux du monde
d'un monde plus juste plus sûr
qu'ensemble nous voulons construire
c'est dans cette perspective il me
semble que la france ne tient pas
suffisamment profit sa situation et de
sa position en amérique du sud
elle doit se considérer comme partie
intégrante de l'amérique latine
je suis pas sûr que nous ayons
suffisamment perçu le profond changement
qui s'est opéré sur ce continent
je sens que subsiste un décalage entre
l'image concerne l'amérique latine dans
une large partie de l'opinion publique
française même éclairé et que c est que
et qu'elle est réellement devenue depuis
quelques années les transformations de
l'amérique latine appel à mon sens une
mobilisation des énergies française pour
répondre un nouvel impératif créé
recréer vers d'autres pays d'amérique
latine qui le veulent la relation
intense et forte qu'ils sont en droit
d'attendre de notre pays et de au delà
de l'europe
nous devons aussi mieux faire connaître
ce que nous sommes et pour cela mieux
diffuser l'image et la voix de la france
aujourd'hui
les distances sont largement aboli
aujourd'hui à nous d'en profiter pour
diffuser notre langue et nos savoir
faire pour assurer le rayonnement de nos
idées notre culture mais changer l'image
de la france en amérique latine s'est
aussi donnée en france une image de
l'amérique latine conforme à la réalité
afin de sensibiliser l'opinion à ce que
représente aujourd'hui les pays de ce
continent notamment dans le domaine de
la création artistique et culturelle si
on propose en l'établissement chaque
année d'une journée d'amérique latine et
des caraïbes en france notre proposition
de résolution pouvait contribuer à ces
prises
conscience je crois que pour cela seule
elle ferait déjà oeuvre utile
le message que ses auteurs souhaitent
finalement adressé à l'amérique latine
tient aujourd'hui en quelques mots la
france et le sénat au premier rang bien
sûr veulent qu'on se l'idée avec les
pays qui la constituent des liens
toujours plus étroits respectueux de
leur indépendance et de leurs
spécificités
fondée sur une culture partagée des
valeurs et des intérêts communs
les objectifs définis ensemble c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues je vous
demande d'apporter votre soutien à la
précède à la présente proposition de
résolution dont l'objet est de marquer
avec force des liens qui unissent la
france au pays de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes et je remercie mon collègue
jean marc pastor de son initiative
il nous appartient de vérifier ce
capital de sympathie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre bel pour le groupe
socialiste pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ambassadeurs
de l'amérique latine et des caraïbes
venus nombreux ce soir à notre rencontre
je m'exprimerai aussi au nom de bernard
piras président du groupe d'amitié
phrase caraïbes qui a dû s'absenter de
notre sénat pour des raisons imprévu la
région des caraïbes est situé au coeur
des deux amériques
elle appartient à l'amérique latine et
elle a partagé les combats de
l'indépendance tout au long du xixème
siècle le signal de la lutte pour
l'indépendance a été lancée depuis haïti
premier pays indépendant de cette région
dès 1804 tandis que le processus
d'émancipation s'est terminée par celle
de cuba en 1898
tous les contacts que nous avons nous et
toutes les rencontres ici ou là depuis
la création du groupe d'amitié s'appuie
sur le partage de valeurs communes qui
repose sur l'admiration du modèle de
liberté offert par la révolution
française c'est l'esprit du siècle des
lumières titre du roman dans l'hérault
carpentier qui inspirait ces mouvements
esprit dont la puissance d'inspiration
demeure active c'est aussi une région où
perdure jean marc pastor l'a dit très
bien tout à l'heure l'amour de la langue
et de la littérature française avec
victor hugo comme fort le combat pour la
langue contre l'uniformisation
culturelle lui ni d'ailleurs les
intérêts français et hispaniques dans
les caraïbes et plus particulièrement
encore dans les antilles françaises
dans ces temps de mondialisation
l'amérique latine de n'est donc plus
lointaines par le coeur comme à travers
des intérêts communs elle est au
contraire proche de nous français ou
européens
chapuis donc entièrement avec conviction
l'adoption de la proposition de
résolution qui vous est présentée je
suis très heureux au nom de mon groupe
politique mais aussi au nom de mes amis
et collègues du
ou peu interparlementaire france
caraïbes que l'instauration d'une
journée de l'amérique latine rappelle
ses liens et les fasse mieux connaître à
travers les nombreuses manifestations
culturelles que je n'en doute pas
suscitera cette célébration
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur gérard cornu
pour le groupe ump pour lui minutes
monsieur le président madame ministre
d'état mes chers collègues
c'est avec beaucoup de plaisir et de
joie que je prends la parole devant tous
les ambassadeurs des pays d'amérique
latine et des caraïbes ici présent que
je salue et je voudrais remercier mon
collègue philippe adnot de me permettre
d'intervenir à ce moment-là contraint
malheureusement par un impératif horaire
vous me permettrez de saluer tout
particulièrement l'initiative prise par
mon ami jean marc pastor qui en sa
qualité de président du comité du
bicentenaire des indépendances des pays
d'amérique latine et des caraïbes a
souhaité marquer la célébration de ce
grand moment de l'histoire des états de
ce continent par le dépôt de la
proposition de résolution consensuelle
co signée par tous les présidents des
groupes d'amitié d'amérique latine et
des caraïbes et bien sûr de nombreux
sénateurs et sénatrices il a ce faisant
voulu marquer la volonté du sénat de la
république de léguer aux générations
futures un repère commémorant l'amitié
entre nos peuples
cette initiative originale est je crois
sans équivalent s'inscrit pour ce qui
concerne le sénat dans une démarche
anciennes c'est en effet en 1950 que le
premier groupe d'amitié france amérique
latine a été créé à l'époque la france
en pleine reconstruction souhaitait
renouer des liens
que la guerre avait quelque peu
distendus et nous collègues d'alors de
façon visionnaire avait estimé que la
haute assemblée devait se doter
d'instruments propre à s'ouvrir sur
l'extérieur et singulièrement vers les
pays qui avaient en commun un patrimoine
culturel et historique éprouvé depuis
lors notre assemblée a créé plusieurs
groupes d'amitié pour prendre davantage
en compte la montée en puissance de ces
nations dans le concert mondial et pour
permettre à ceux de nos collègues
nombreux qui portent un intérêt soutenu
à ces pays à leur culture bien sûr mais
aussi à leurs évolutions stratégiques
politiques économiques de s'y impliquer
davantage notre assemblée a tenu l'an
dernier en 2010 a célébré avec ses
moyens institutionnels mais surtout avec
la force de conviction dont elle est
capable
ces grands moments que furent la
libération de l'amérique latine et des
caraïbes
sans doute y at il une part de
convenance dans le choix des dates tout
nat a commencé exactement il ya 200 ans
et tout ne s'est pas achevée dans le
courant de la même année
loin s'en faut mais il suffit de retenir
que dans les soubresauts de cette longue
histoire
la france fut souvent le point de
référence pour les acteurs de
l'émancipation des peuples
et cela sous toutes les latitudes la
trilogie liberté égalité fraternité
reste aujourd'hui encore étroitement
associée à notre pays
même si elle est devenue depuis deux
siècles un héritage universel chacun le
partage et chacun temps de le faire
fructifier à son rythme au début de ce
21e siècle
nous sommes particulièrement heureux de
pouvoir compter tous ces pays au nombre
des nations qui partagent notre idéal
démocratique ce qui était loin d'être le
cas
il y à 50 ans à peine
et alors que l'on voit aujourd'hui dans
d'autres régions du monde des peuples se
soulevaient pour réclamer à leur tour
le bénéfice de ces valeurs fondamentales
de la condition humaine
nous ne pouvons qu'approuver cette
résolution en formant le voeu qu'elle
servira d'inspiration pour les pays qui
n'en connaissent pas les bienfaits
nous souhaitons donc que s'instaure dans
notre pays cette journée de l'amérique
latine et des caraïbes et qu'elles
deviennent au fil des ans un grand
rendez-vous de joie et d'amitié et
fortifie si besoin était les liens
forgés par l'histoire
c'est pourquoi avec mes collègues
cosignataires du texte et avec les
collègues de mon groupe je voterai la
présente proposition de résolution
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur philippe adnot pour les non
inscrits pour 3 minutes
le
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vos excellences monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues vous avez remarqué je
n'ai que trois minutes puisque non
inscrits donc je vais d'abord remercié
jean marc pour lui dire qu'il a été
tellement bon et qui a exprimé avec
tellement de talent ce que l'on pense
tous que d'une certaine manière je me
sens libéré
ça n'est pas grave si je n'ai que trois
minutes
j'ai souhaité cosigné en ma qualité de
président du groupe d'amitié france pays
andin c'est à dire la bolivie la
colombie l'équateur le pérou et le
venezuela cette proposition de
résolution visant à instituer en france
une journée de l'amérique latine et des
caraïbes
je l'est d'autant plus que souhaité que
l'année 2010 a été marquée par la
célébration du bicentenaire des
indépendances des pays d'amérique latine
et des caraïbes est ce pas dire que
grâce à la mobilisation de la société
civile des collectivités des acteurs de
la relation franco latino-américaine
plus de 150 projets dans les domaines
artistiques économiques universitaires
et du débat l'idée ont reçu le label de
cette manifestation et ça s'est déployée
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire
ces événements ont permis de mettre en
lumière non seulement les projets
communs qui unissent nos pays mais aussi
la force la richesse et l'actualité des
liens entre la france et l'amérique
latine
l'instauration de cette date marquera
ainsi l'importance des liens tissés au
cours de ces deux siècles entre ces
mêmes états et la france la volonté de
marquer de façon symbolique
la force de nos relations nous remémorer
cette année joyeuse ne doit pas nous
empêcher de nous souvenir des événements
dramatiques qui ont touché notamment la
colombie et la région de medellin avec
les accidents climatiques qui ont été
que dont ils ont été le théâtre et je
voudrais qu'on cet instant justement
notre joie ne nous évite pas de penser à
ceux qui ont des problèmes
notre compassion et profonde parce que
nous sommes attachés à l'amérique latine
mais aussi parce que nous avons une
empathie culturel une filiation entre la
naissance de ces états et l'esprit des
lumières et la révolution française et
je pense aussi que nous partageons le
fort désir de tous ses états et de leurs
peuples d'un vrai développement
économique parce que celui ci est la
base même de l'évolution aussi dans le
domaine du social de l'éducation et de
la liberté cette amitié qui nous lie et
sincère elle est déliée de tout jugement
de valeur sur les différents
gouvernements car ceux ci sont le fruit
de leur histoire de leur situation du
moment et nous devons absolument nous
respecter les uns les autres si nous
voulons nous comprendre et cette
compréhension doit nous amener également
à comprendre que chacun des pays est
libre de mener sa politique et d'être
maître de son destin et je pense
notamment à la manière d'utiliser les
ressources naturelles
la présente proposition de résolution
exprime bien me semble-t-il notre
aspiration en faveur d'une évolution
favorable des rapports entre nos pays
du point de vue de la sécurité juridique
d'une part parce qu'elle est nécessaire
aux échanges économiques et donc à la
loyauté de ses échanges
notre compréhension s'approfondira grâce
à ce texte et à tout ce qu'on pourra
faire ensemble parce que ce sera la base
des différents ports qui doivent
conduire donc ces échanges qu'ils soient
culturels qu'ils soient éducatif et je
voulais saluer la présence extrêmement
forte
des étudiants dans
no dans notre pays et je dois dire que
personnellement puisque j'ai conduit une
petite analyse pour quantifier la
présence ces étudiants j'ai été vraiment
extrêmement intéressé par la force de
ses relations qui je le crois seront la
base des futures relations qui doivent
s'instituer entre nos différents pays
monsieur le président bah oui trois
minutes savait pas beaucoup je voudrais
simplement dire que le scénar aborde
cette révolution avec l'unité qui
l'humilité qui convient à des rapports
fraternels basée sur le respect commun
mais aussi avec la conviction que notre
amitié peut faire naître un monde plus
juste plus humain offrant plus
d'espérance pas seulement à la france et
aux pays d'amérique latine mais à
l'ensemble des habitants de notre
planète
mais si chaque collègue la parole et à
monsieur françois fortassin pour le
groupe rds pour sept minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues au moment de gagner
ses tribunes c'est un fort sentiment
d'émotion qui me gagne sous le regard
bienveillant et attentif d'une forte
délégation diplomatique différents pays
d'amérique latine
et puis parce que je considère que c'est
un moment très fort pour l'autre sénat
l'amérique latine c'est avant tout des
rêves d'enfants et d'adolescents qui ne
se souvient parc ses habitants pauvres
des alpes du sud du queyras et de
barcelonnette sont partis à la conquête
mexico où ils ont créé le bazar de
mexico et fortune fait un certain nombre
sont revenus dans notre pays
bien entendu c'est ni grande du queyras
sont les plus symboliques mais on en
trouve dans toutes les campagnes
françaises
et permettez moi de saluer l'initiative
de notre collègue jean marc pastor très
attaché à l'amérique latine comme les
différents signataires de cette
résolution comme expert de ses voyages
en amérique latine mais qui a saisit
bien entendu tout ce que l'on pouvait
tirer d'une relation extrêmement forte
que nous devons avoir avec ces pays
il faut bien dire d'ailleurs que les
gens qui comme moi pratique modestement
là c'est le castillan mais la dore
sont aussi attirés par la musique latino
américaines sont extrêmement sensibles à
tout ce qui est proche de l'amérique
latine lorsqu'on est en amérique latine
on se sent chez soi on a une proximité
avec tous les habitants quelles que
soient les pays dans lesquels on se
promène j'ai eu la chance de me rendre à
peu près dans sept ou huit pays
d'amérique latine et j'ai toujours
ressenti à la fois cette chaleur et puis
aussi c'est le bonheur quelquefois des
populations les plus pauvres de nous
rendre l'hospitalité et en même temps de
considérer comme un véritable honneur
que nous soyons français que nous
intéressions à ce continent latino
américain
il faut dire qu'il y a des relations
aussi très étroites jean marc pastor a
évoqué bolivar c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup aimé la france
il s'est inspiré des siècles des
lumières
il a été ce qui est que l'on connaît -
il était présent au sacre napoléon 1er
c'est dire combien il avait la volonté
d'être ce libertador et un libertador
c'est beaucoup plus qu'un libérateur
c'est celui qui brise les chaînes de
l'oppression mais qui dégage en même
temps un profond mouvement d'espoir et
d'espérance car au plus dans les pires
difficultés qu'ont connu ces peuples ils
n'ont jamais perdu l'espoir de la
liberté car ils se sont toujours
accrochés à cet espoir que susciter la
france pour toute l'amérique la france
le latine la france
c'est la patrie des libertés c'est la
patrie des droits de l'homme et c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles lui en
tenue nous avons des devoirs vis-à-vis
de l'amérique latine
et si tous ces pays par l'espagnol le
portugais pour le brésil il est évident
que nombre d'entre eux sont très
francophile à commencer par ce petit
pays qui est l'uruguay où il ya encore
quelques années on parlait français dans
la rue et ou de poètes ont une renommée
extraordinaire en uruguay et
personnellement il me sens un parti que
puisque qui sont originaires de tarbes
dans les hautes-pyrénées
il s'agit d'isidore ducasse et jules
laforgue ce sont des auteurs qui en
uruguay sont quasiment aussi connu que
peut l'être victor hugo dans notre pays
et puis l'amérique latine
elle a quand même fait un énorme pas en
avant en direction de la démocratie cela
a été souligné
il faut savoir que de nombreux pays
avaient encore il y à quelques dizaines
d'années des régimes d'oppression des
régimes difficile et très souvent les
transitions se sont faites de façon
relativement naturelle toujours parce
que les leaders étaient guidés par ce
sentiment profond que le développement
ne peut exister que dans la mesure où on
est dans un pays démocratique et c'est
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui la
plupart de ces pays même s'ils ont des
problèmes connaissent un essor
économique incontestable
et puis il y à aussi en amérique latine
des richesses
richesse culturelle richert de coeur des
habitants de l'amérique latine
quel qu'il soit mais aussi richesse de
l'immensité de ces pays ou encore du
sous-sol et nous avons là aussi en
termes de géopolitique une
incontestablement un rôle important à
jouer
nous ne pouvons pas laisser ces pays
d'amérique latine à la merci de leur
grand voisin américain
d'autant plus que la grande
caractéristique des etats-unis
lorsqu'ils sont implantés en amérique
latine pour la plupart et j'en suis bien
entendu cette affirmation
ils n'ont rien compris à l'amérique
latine et c'est d'ailleurs pour la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui la
france c'est une des raisons
supplémentaires est tellement apprécié
en amérique latine alors voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire monsieur le
président vous avez vu que j'ai tenu
parfaitement le temps en nous disant que
je vous ferais bien entendu avec
enthousiasme cette résolution
merci chers collègues et bien la parole
est maintenant madame marie agnès
labarre pour le groupe crc spg pour sept
minutes
j'ai commencé monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues
messieurs les ambassadeurs l'institution
d'une journée de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes en france nous permettra
d'éclairer et de resserrer les liens qui
nous unissent avec cette partie du monde
en effet les racines de nos deux espaces
s'entrecroisent et particulièrement
celles qui résultent de la révolution de
1789 les sociétés d'amérique latine sont
des sociétés imprégné du sens du droit
comme le sont toutes et société romaine
du droit écrit notre démocratie et
celles de l'amérique latine s'abreuvent
donc à des sources communes notamment le
fait de concevoir la citoyenneté comme
résultant d'un contrat politique et non
des liens du sang à ce parallélisme
politique se superpose une dimension
culturelle l'impact de la grande
révolution de 1789 sur les événements
d'amérique latine celle influence des
idées idées des lumières sur les créoles
d'amérique latine
et c'est aussi la culture
révolutionnaire qui a conduit nos
voisins latino américains à interroger
leur lien à la royauté
nous savons comment cette culture a
transité
nous savons que le premier texte sur les
droits de l'homme est arrivé en amérique
latine aux mains des espagnols déportés
à caracas comme le monde est petit et
que l'histoire est brève
le directeur de la prison francs maçons
comme les déporter les aida à recopier
le premier texte de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui sera
imprimé en guadeloupe en espagnol et
reviendra ensuite sur le continent
latino américain
avant ces événements il y avait de
nombreuses secousses annonciatrice en
particulier la lutte des république
noire et notamment haïti avec victor
hugues la séquence de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé dans le nouveau monde a
libéré une main
dejean ces gens d'un courage
extraordinaire fut réputé sulfureux par
la bourgeoisie locale
on les appelait le aux français
cessent les noirs français à qui il
était absolument interdit d'arriver sur
le territoire des bourbons cave on les
soupçonnait d'être contaminé par l'idéal
révolutionnaire
dès lors les noirs français sont partis
à l'assaut du venezuela pour y établir
ce qu'ils avaient exemple est la loi des
français la république et l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
souvenons nous qu'en suit presque tous
les libertador simon bolivar et d'autres
comme le général venezuela miranda qui a
participé à la guerre de libération et
d'indépendance nationale et dont le nom
est inscrit sur l'arc de triomphe à
paris sont passés par la france
n'en déplaise aux observateurs qui ne
tiennent pas compte de l'influencé des
courants profonds de l'histoire il
existe bien une relation organique entre
le nouveau monde et la france la patrie
républicaine origine l issue du choc de
1780 89 des droits de l'homme et de
l'idéal républicain
tous ces éléments doivent être présents
à notre esprit pour bien comprendre que
les révolutions démocratiques à l'oeuvre
en amérique latine depuis la fin des
années 90 nous concerne également cette
vague révolutionnaire tire sa force de
la cour de conjonction de deux éléments
le rejet d'une politique libérale
appliquées au-delà de tout ce qu'on
avait pu imaginer et le patriotisme
latino-américain progressiste et anti
impérialiste le parti de gauche se
réfère à ces événements pour trois
raisons d'abord parce qu'il s'agit de
révolution ensuite parce qu'elles sont
démocratiques et ensuite parce qu'elles
sont pour principal objectif la
reconquête de la souveraineté populaire
le déploiement de cette vague
révolutionnaire en particulier à partir
du venezuela permet de comprendre ce qui
va se passer en france ce qui va se
produire aussi naturellement que
l'alternance démarré sur nos rives
atlantique
la révolution citoyenne a d'ores et déjà
traversé l'atlantique en islande d'abord
ne peut pas décider à 95% de rejeter le
sauvetage des banques et à convoquer une
assemblée constituante dans le monde
arabe ensuite où les tunisiens les
égyptiens pour résoudre la question
sociale commenceront par résoudre la
question démocratique le dégagé tunisien
fait écho à qu'ils s'en aillent tous de
la révolution argentine chômage
inégalités croissantes autoritarisme les
problèmes auxquels les problèmes
auxquels sont confrontés les peuples du
maghreb et du mc rae après les peuples
d'amérique latine sont les mêmes que
ceux que rencontrent nos concitoyens la
contagion de ces mouvements populaires
nous concerne donc elle nous réjouit car
ici aussi la lutte contre une oligarchie
est à l'ordre du jour l'oligarchie qui
en renflouant les banques sans
contrepartie en volant deux ans de
retraite aux salariés ne cesse de faire
payer la crise aux classes populaires et
aux classes moyennes qui vont bientôt
d'en faire plus qu'une celle qui
maintient les jeunes au chômage les
agriculteurs dans la détresse celle qui
dresse les ouvriers contre les chômeurs
qui fait le tri entre les bons français
avec papier les autres dépositaires
indésirables de la misère du monde celle
qui fleure ostensiblement avec les
despotes qu'elle a fabriqué tout exprès
celle enfin qui verrouille les médias
sans se rende compte que le monde de
l'information libre et spontané a balayé
la nouvelle et ou rtf oui messieurs les
français parlent tous français
les tunisiens aux tunisiens les
résistants aux résistants par internet
facebook twitter
les jeunes ont le mode d'emploi de la
liberté de l'égalité de la fraternité la
révolution citoyenne nous revient donc
d'amérique latine
elle est la bienvenue pour des millions
de français qui souffrent comme en
tunisie et en egypte aujourd'hui c'est
une nouvelle libération pour la france
qui s'annonce
vous qui nous gouvernent et réunissez
les ingrédients qui bientôt nous
permettront de reconquérir par les unes
les urnes notre souveraineté populaire
face aux décisions antidémocratiques du
fmi et de la commission européenne qui
font payer partout la crise aux pauvres
ironie de l'histoire la révolution de
1789 a été notamment le fruit de la
volonté du parlement de décider de son
budget grâce à vous et aux béni oui oui
de l'union européenne
notre parlement aura bientôt délocaliser
son droit de contrôle budgétaire
quelle régression quel aveuglement
mesdames qui gouverner sans les peuples
parfois contre eux comme lors du
référendum de 2005
vous nous faites revenir deux siècles en
arrière prenez garde que les mêmes
causes ne produisent pas les mêmes
effets vous allez bientôt créé une
surpopulation cap notre
charm-el-cheikh hexagonal ainsi cette
résolution tombe à toi nommé nous lave
autos ont bien évidemment pour célébrer
notre lien avec l'amérique latine qui
nous a ouvert la voie de la reconquête
de la souveraineté populaire
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame michèle alliot marie ministre
d'état ministre des affaires étrangères
et européennes le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la résolution que vous présentez
aujourd'hui à l'initiative de monsieur
pastor marque certainement une nouvelle
étape dans l'amitié entre la france et
l'amérique latine et les caraïbes
elle s'inscrit cette résolution dans la
continuité avec la célébration en 2010
du bicentenaire des indépendances
je sais que le sénat qui a pris toute sa
part et d'ailleurs messieurs cornu yanal
ont rappelé cette résolution souligne
aussi la volonté de la france de
s'appuyer sur le lien exceptionnel qui
nous unis avec l'amérique latine et les
caraïbes pour construire entre tous ces
pays une relation qui souhaitent une
relation ambitieuse vous avez mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs rappeler les
liens étroits qui unissent la france et
des pays d'amérique latine et des
caraïbes
ce sont d'abord des liens que
géographique car ne l'oublions pas on
oublie effectivement trop souvent la
france est présente dans les caraïbes et
elle l'est aussi en amérique latine à
partir de la guyane la martinique la
guadeloupe et la guyane aussi contribuer
au rayonnement de notre pays et
contribuer à l'établissement de ses
liens avec l'ensemble des pays de la
zone
mais au delà des liens géographiques ce
sont aussi des liens intellectuels nous
savons le rôle qu'ont joué les penseurs
des lumières
dans l'émancipation des peuples
d'amérique latine et des caraïbes et
nous mesurons la richesse des échanges
entre nos pays qui évoque bien sûr les
noms de braudel de lévi-strauss de
lautréamont ou le clézio de victor hugo
deux sites est monsieur bell sans
oublier bien sûr les tarbais comme nous
l'ont comme nous l'a rappelé monsieur
fortassin ce sont aussi des liens
effectivement institutionnel et
politique et je pense aux parents tes
institutionnelles entre la france et une
partie des états de la région à des
conceptions constitutionnel qui sont les
mêmes je pense à la culture juridique
commune aussi je pensais également aux
liens tissés avec les exilés d'amérique
latine pendant les années noires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
soyons lucides tous ceux qui sont ici
s'intéresse aux relations entre la
france et les pays d'amérique du sud et
des caraïbes
pour autant il faut bien noter que ces
liens on tue pendant un certain temps
une certaine distance la politique de la
france a tardé à donner à l'amérique
latine toute la place qu'elle mérite et
je crois que tous ceux qui sont ici sont
attachés à ce que le temps perdu soit
rattrapé la france se tient aujourd'hui
au côté de l'amérique latine et des
caraïbes pour relever des défis qui sont
des défis d'un avenir que nous avons en
commun
alors bien sûr il ya l'actualité et on
ne saurait non plus l'oublier
l'actualité se concentre aujourd'hui sur
la situation de florence cassez
nous avons amitié et respect pour le
mexique et le peuple mexicain et nous
savons la gravité de la situation en
matière d'enlèvement
nous respectons l'indépendance de la
justice au mexique comme partout notre
mobilisation en faveur de florence
cassez se fonde justement sur les valeur
de justice et d'attachement à l'état de
droit que nous avons en partage
encore une fois elle ne remet pas en
cause notre amitié à l'égard du peuple
mexicain
elle n'entame en rien notre volonté de
conforter nos liens avec les
pl d'amérique latine et des caraïbes la
zone amérique latine-caraïbes s'affirme
comme un acteur majeur de l'univers
multipolaire qui se dessine sous nos
yeux nos pays partagent la même vision
de la mondialisation la zone amérique
latine caraïbes est au coeur des
problématiques globales le changement
climatique qu'il affecte directement la
préservation de la biodiversité dont
l'amérique latine détient une part
majeure la sécurité alimentaire un
multilatéralisme rénové doit nous
conduire à apporter des réponses
globales aux questions globales
la france soutient l'amérique latine sur
la scène internationale oui monsieur du
luart vous avez raison nous allons le
faire nous voulons que l'amérique latine
retrouve toute sa place au sein du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu et c'est
pourquoi la france souhaite que le
brésil en soit un membre permanent
qu'il s'agisse de réformer le système
monétaire international de lutter contre
la volatilité des prix des matières
premières ou de rééquilibrer la
gouvernance mondiale le continent sud
américain doit faire entendre sa voix la
france y travaille en coopération
étroite avec les pays sud américain dans
le cadre du g20 la france veut aussi
contribuer concrètement à l'essor de la
zone amérique du sud caraïbes le
développement économique et social et la
contrepartie de la stabilité
l'instabilité l'engendrent mais le
développement économique et social est
une condition de la stabilité
ce développement économique et social
entraîne des besoins considérables pour
y répondre
la france a des atouts à faire valoir
toutes nos grandes entreprises sont
présentes sur le continent et sur des
créneaux stratégie qu'il s'agisse de
l'aéronautique qu'il s'agisse des
transports de l'énergie ou des
infrastructures et aujourd'hui la france
figure parmi les premiers investisseurs
au venezuela en colombie au brésil nos
exportations ont augmenté
20 % en cinq ans parfois les industriels
sont en avance sur les politiques
et pourtant il reste encore du chemin à
faire même dans ce domaine notre part de
marché de l'ordre de 2% fait un acteur
bien trop modeste et c'est l'un des
enjeux de notre stratégie à l'égard de
l'amérique latine et des caraïbes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'amitié entre nos pays et toute entière
tournée vers l'avenir
la france doit être plus présente pour
accompagner la prospérité économique de
l'amérique latine
la france va assurer davantage le
rayonnement culturel qui est
traditionnellement le sien dans cette
partie du monde
le gouvernement soutient donc la
proposition de résolution proposé par le
sénat
la journée du 31 mai fera honneur à
notre histoire commune et à nos idéaux
partagés
elle accompagnera les efforts de la
diplomatie française en faveur de cette
région du monde
elle sensibilisera j'en suis sûr nos
concitoyens à la solidarité qui nous
unit à la volonté qui nous rassemble
face aux défis de la modernité
merci madame la ministre je vais mettre
voit la proposition de résolution j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste sur la
proposition de résolution
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront ce cas tu es un
bulletin blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter
contre remettront un bulletin bleu ce
qui soit s'abstenir au métro un bulletin
rouge le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
toi tu as aimé
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 161 sur la
proposition de résolution présentée en
application de l'article 34 de la
constitution relatives à l'institution
d'une journée de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes en france nombre de votants
338 nombre de suffrages exprimés
338 pour l'adoption 338
le sénat a adopté la proposition de
résolution
c'est la fin de cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire cet après midi
15h très bonne journée à tous
hop